there do I see my mother
hold there do I see my father
well they're do they call to me so for
those of you who have been playing or
watching god of war I'm sure that you
have a host of questions and today will
attempt to answer one that is
undoubtedly near the top of your list
who exactly is a Tracy's mother over the
course of this video we'll explore who
she was in the game and how those
depictions differed and compared to
those of Norse mythology as will be
common with most of my god of war videos
they will contain spoilers so if you do
not want to be spoiled than I urge you
to please click away we first see it
raises mother near the very beginning of
the game in quite an emotional scene
where a trace essentially says goodbye
to his mother performing some kind of
funeral rites before her body is
cremated in the game she's referred to
as Fey and Melissa believed that she was
a mortal woman making a trace a demigod
but as the game progresses we quickly
learned that Fey had been concealing her
true nature from her family for reasons
unknown to us with Kratos spending most
of his time away from home a choice
would spend most of his days of his
mother it was because of Fey that a
trace began to use a bow as she told her
son how to hunt and track prey we're not
exactly told how they died
but it's something that will surely be
touched upon later on in the series and
we can make the assumption that her
death may not have been from natural
causes
we learned that Fey was in fact a giant
from the realm of Jotunheim murmuring
crater sonnet Reyes eventually traveled
to Jotunheim they see a collection of
murals and inscriptions on the wall with
Fey had previously prophesized
everything that would happen in the game
in these markings at Reyes is referred
to as Loki and Kratos does avoid that
that was the name his mother wanted for
him but instead they went with at Reyes
a fallen comrade and friend of Kratos
when he served in the Spartan army we
now know that the trace is half god and
half yotan or giant as it's commonly
referred to in their game but there's
still so much a mystery that surrounds
Fey and her intentions for her son and
her husband when phase a she's
eventually scattered in Jotunheim
Mamiya suggests that a trace and Kratos
may have bought about Ragnarok a hundred
years earlier than expected so now that
we have a rough idea of how she appears
in the game we can compare and contrast
these depictions that out of Norse
mythology so to start off Loki's mother
in Norse mythology does not go by the
name Fey but instead she's referred to
as la Fey or lui vey
as it's pronounced icelandic
with Loki sometimes been referred to as
La Fea arson meaning la fête son it
would seem that God [ __ ] definitely
took some influence from this name I
assume they shortened it to Fey in an
attempt to keep it simple and easy to
remember there are a few accounts where
she was instead referred to as null and
some believe that this meant needle
which would relate to depictions of her
as slender and weak depictions that
subtly contrast what we see in the game
when we first meet Sindri he describes
her as a strong woman in a fierce
warrior and any other character to refer
to Fey
generally does so in high regard to
clear up a very common misconception and
many have from the Marvel comics and
movies
Loki's biological father was not Odin of
course in the game that role belongs to
Kratos but in traditional Norse
mythology his father was far a booty
which endorsement CRO hitter or fish
striker it's thought that Lafayette self
could possibly mean full of leaves or
even pine needles which meant that many
interpreted Loki's birth as a fish
strike of lightning hit in the leaves
and needles at the bottom of a tree
causing fire to rise
Loki was not la fête only child she had
two more sons by last ear and held Lindy
and although they don't really feature
much in Norse mythology help Lindy's
name suggests that he was either blind
or enjoyed poking out the eyes of others
depictions of La Fea very brief and
ambiguous some believe that she was a
goddess and others that she was a yotan
or a giant
were gada for makes it very play within
the game that she was a giant from the
realm of Jotunheim it's important to
note that not all yo towns were giants
they came in all shapes and forms so in
short we don't actually know what Loki's
mother looked like and it does raise
some interesting questions that the game
would have to answer regarding how she
was able to conceal her appearance if
she was a giant and why she left yo tin
home it's interesting to see what
direction they take with Fay in future
games as there aren't many descriptive
depictions of her given them free rein
to experiment without having to worry
about upsetting too many people another
fairly noticeable comparison that we can
make between game and mythology is that
la Fey was the name connected with
nature
something was somewhat see in the game
as it was Fey who taught at race out to
hunt and track animals and perhaps her
connection with nature is something I'll
be explored in future gotta four
installments
because of the lack of surviving texts
and sources surrounding Loki's mother
and father it's very hard to make any
real comparisons between how they
feature in the game and how they feature
in Norse mythology but I'd love to hear
what you guys think and how you'd like
to see fay depicted in future games feel
free to share any thoughts and ideas
have been in the comments below